um
yeah
do you hear taika
we are
still in Vegas we are in the Mount
Charleston area this morning look at how
gorgeous this is
can you believe this maybe you can but I
can't because my lame ass California ass
has never
seen anything like this in her backyard
like this I mean we do have big bear but
bro
is it anything close to this
what's up
wanted to get out of the house today get
with some nature now that we have Papa
back from California just wanted to go
out do something but it's been so hot in
Summerlin Vegas area I don't know what
this is Mount Charleston tomorrow
up in the mountains a bit
um yeah it's gonna be like 107 today
and I'm like but I want to get out so we
came up here and it feels let me see
66 degrees right now it's 66 degrees oh
is it yeah it's so comfortable whoa
don't do that that's for doggies
I told him to keep on the lookout if we
see these guys oh
it's so cute we're at Cathedral Rock
right now
[Applause]
no more no more no more
we're already getting in trouble
let's go let's explore
monkey monkey what'd you see chocolate
in a bag chocolate in a bag so
disgusting
so Bart has this thing that he tells
taika all the time if what happens every
time you see poop every time I see poop
I go Hey look it's chocolate and he goes
in the beginning he didn't understand
the game so he's like that's not
chocolate
statue of liberty liberty Statue of
Liberty boy but then now he knows the
game so when he sees poo poo too he goes
hey papa look at chocolate in a bag
Statue of Liberty let's go dude
how beautiful is his spot
I almost feel bad that I'm like wearing
sunglasses because it's like colorizing
it you know yeah versus like it's not
I'm not taking it in before it should be
so I'm gonna turn my sunglasses around
nice
this is gorgeous I love it here already
and we haven't even started
they're not the fire ants are red those
are Mungus look at these guys they're
massive black medium man look at the
that's the scale it's the size of my
thumbnail
no
way you know
you don't know those things why would
you do that
there's a little chipmunk
it started off as a song I didn't mean
for it he's moving his little Telltale
where is he put that on the little
Branch right there I see him he's not
moving that's like guys
okay you're the one dressed like a
bright flower
the CUNY guy
you guys I love it here this is an
absolute dream come true like
what it's beautiful this is so perfect
look at that
and they're so like I saw a chipmunk
like what
Gemma so cute
I love it here I'll never leave here
gotta just move
no don't don't aggravate it like that
because you commit and you get angry
oh they're gone look how cool this is so
this is pretty high altitude we've only
been on the hike for maybe like 10
minutes maybe and it says already went
up 10 flights of stairs so the altitude
is pretty steep and I can feel my breath
going
you know even like a world-class athlete
like me when I get tired that means
everyone else gonna get tired so it's
cool that they have uh
we've been sitting down like a lazy bum
oh okay
thank you
they're playing hide and go seek
hey human can't talk
look at how beautiful this Trail is
yeah get your wiggles out dude
video
let me pop over there
getting some artistic shots
we have people closing in on us
let's keep moving
he's coming
keep hiding
so beautiful I'm definitely winded
look at that
ah there's a cat here
like I heard a cat
aha
hey there you are
oh boys
mid I think it's more than midpoint
check I think we're right about at the
end
and there's been a train change
it's so Gravelly but it's more wood
than the rocks that it was before
it's so beautiful
oh
look at all these little guys oh yeah
they're not squirrels
why'd I call them squirrels oh my God is
this heaven or what
and by the way
we've made it to the top
look at this
tree
[Music]
so cute
everywhere
look at them
look how cute
they want to eat the Cranberries
oh my gosh hi dudes yeah
[Music]
cute huh
okay look at taika
you guys trying to tickle them
that was really good he's right here
everybody
I wish I could take one home yeah
everyone does they're so cute
so cute huh
squares
oh they heard your they heard your
advertisement do you have a customer
he's selling meds I'm selling nuts I'm
selling berries and selling berries I'm
selling berries I'm selling batteries
I'm selling berries I'm selling them so
don't
we all ended up sleeping in the car and
by all just me and taika Papa did all
the driving I slept too I felt really I
feel it was so refreshed how far was the
drive
um it's only 30 minutes bad yeah so we
woke up and during the hike because it
was so it was actually pretty difficult
because it's going uphill the entire way
we told taika that if he completed it
[Music]
that we would be we would take him a
7-Eleven to get some
questions
what flavor are we gonna get
it who do you think we're at right now
oh yeah buddy let's go get our slushies
boom boom shakalaka
same
here we go
the monkey got his little slipper slurps
this is the one
this is the winner winner chicken dinner
mother
[Music]
you're right over there
oh God
Oh no you're that guy oh Jesus
[Applause]
oh my God how did you get yours I helped
them oh okay okay how is it
everything you ever dreamed of is it
perfect
[Applause]
[Music]
clearly you know we're still dieting
so that was bomb yeah
go
ah it's too good
excuse me okay let's go Chef Papa coming
through let me blower the volume type as
much from Spider-Man in the background
look at this
just keep in mind that it's diet is that
even Chef worthy or is that just garbage
you know what when you're on a diet and
you can't eat anything anyway yeah this
is Gourmet
you need a little bit of everything is
that what's happening [ __ ] yeah
you just blew it all off the spoon
is it good yeah it's a hearty it is I
just don't like the flavored chicken and
I could taste the chicken I know but we
have leftover chicken so we're trying to
yeah we're using it utilize it no that
makes my heart happy but yeah chicken
my least favorite or maybe I just don't
know how to prepare it correctly but I
just never liked the taste of chicken
but it's bombs usually chicken is the
most agreeable meat in the universe
everyone loves chicken well I would find
a way to fight with it okay you find a
way about it
I made the joke first loser
what do you got going on over there whoa
young lady so as we've been talking
about since
few months back we've been running our
bar Bob Brigade program yeah
um our get lean program and this is our
last couple of days running the program
which means for the next couple of days
after the program's done we get to do
this thing called a cheat meal where
we're just gonna go off the rails eat
whatever we want to eat for the next few
days and then get back on track and
start cutting again new program
um and in that time we went to Eddie's
world and Papa was looking for some
peanut brittle yeah they didn't have to
find any yeah so while you were out in
California
um I looked up a recipe to make peanut
brittle and it's actually really easy so
you found you found one that's diet
friendly it's easy no this is for off
the rails dude oh this is off the rail
stuff I'm gonna make me legit legit
peanut butter yeah yeah yeah that's CUNY
you care about me huh no I just want to
cook you're cute yeah so it seemed easy
on paper so I'm gonna attempt to make it
for you today excuse me can I eat
something well I can't then I'm gonna
eat it today huh
that's what I'm saying it's good for how
am I gonna resist I mean if you taste it
a little bit it's fine the only bummers
I couldn't find on salted peanuts gonna
be salted so we'll see what that
experience is like so I'm sorry in
advance real quick okay what's going on
here I don't know I need to focus I
can't answer your questions oh day it's
like a cooking show yeah oh wow what
that is crazy what is that peanut butter
I've never seen anything like that so
cool yeah this is nuts wow damn did I
marry Gordon Ramsay or something I mean
let's taste it first yeah it smells good
horrible it smells really good is that
like caramel what is that uh like you do
caramelize the corn syrup that's what
you're asking I don't know how to hold
on can I lick that spoon
yeah is this sweet yes it's done okay
let me give it another spoon here
this looks kind of nice
I'm not sure is it really I'm not sure
if I put too much baking soda in or not
I feel like I kind of did
oh no oh no
save it save the potato griddle why
what's happening you don't want it to
break apart just yet oh
it tastes like it has the making of
being something delicious is it
right no I'm trying already yeah it's
like cookie dough where like it's not
the final product but it's like getting
really close
I think I did a good job
this is way more expensive than just
buying it from the store you're buying
all the ingredients um but I can make it
like in it again and again and again so
if you know me expect some peanut
brittle for them
Papa yeah it's all dry so essentially
this is what should happen Okay it
should just slide right off and you
should be able to just it in one piece
just crack it and it might not but it
should be able to slide right off not
stick yeah and you just begin
crack-a-lacking okay you ready to crack
a lot monkey okay hold on I'll give you
something
you just turn the pan around maybe like
just switch the pan yeah like that yeah
like just like twist the pan twist it
yeah there you go oh it's one solid
piece look at that yeah just start
cracking it break it
hey shh not like that Duty
you don't have to whisper either sorry I
did say
let me get to let me get some
I did that don't too hard a little bit
um
yeah no you crack it they crack like
this little by little
hey good job thank you
this is really good thank you
yep
so super excited about how my peanut
brittle turned out it was so good I feel
like I'm gonna start making this now for
like little presents and stuff like
holidays or whatever you know something
I could contribute something that I made
with my own hands that you cannot buy
because I didn't make it
um but we had promised taika today that
we would take him bowling so this is the
first time I'm ever even at this because
you know what is this called Suncoast
yeah it's one of the other local casinos
the Summerlin they try to cross the
street from taboli Village to cross the
street from tavoli Village
so we're at Suncoast never been here
um we normally went to the um Red Rock
Bowling Alley
excuse you
but I don't like it I didn't like it for
little kids maybe if we were an older
crowd like they squished too many people
in Lanes so if you have little kids I'm
talking about like
I don't know that have zero spatial
awareness don't go there
um it was just a [ __ ] show so we're
gonna check this one out okay
what happened so taika has a tradition
of pressing all of these buttons I don't
know why I don't know why he went ninja
mode this time and he kicked it with the
shin oh that's Muay Thai style baby yeah
but I just I don't know what you think
it was made out of yeah let's go up the
elevator well so far it smells really
nice in here it smells like really nice
see you later
there you go hey hey hey
found it
oh this looks like a traditional bowling
alley
cool there's a little arcade
look monkey there's a traditional food
oh God Pizza
whoa
over there probably right here
I think so
[Applause]
there is no lanes for today so we're
gonna go to the arcade
oh dude let's play this one
your mom is the best at this game your
mom is way better than your papa at this
game
all right for the ultimate Quan family
championships
it's crazy because it starts off as a
normal game watch you see that it's
already not normal okay once it drops in
the middle he's just chilling
oh no
help here his arms are too short okay
there you go there you go oh no
hey there we go there's the game there
we go
hey cutie whoa oh
[Applause]
do that score
[Music]
[Music]
look how big he is go go
move to the side move to the side
so cute I just can't
[Music]
isn't it cute
[Applause]
okay he's a little drunk driver but
we'll get the hang of it
stop hitting the wall you're losing
okay so he doesn't care to win he just
cares to be funny I wonder where he gets
that from
this was that funny
oh my God
[Music]
let's see if I can get his face
[Music]
dude these games are so cool check this
one out
he's laughing at you
there
you go
what don't say that
good job
why
I don't know
what did you say that they do that you
want to do like them
is that what police officers do yeah
baby kidney
so take out of nowhere says uh that he
wants to be a police officer when he
grows up and then that was his answer as
to why I know it's so funny I was like
I'm gonna take you to jail and you take
Unity of Papa to jail yep when he
doesn't let you have dessert huh yeah
I hope I bought that
oh
in a few days you're gonna be eating
desserts all day long
how you feel about that monkey uh
usually when they have dessert that I
would pick you up and enjoy it into jail
and throw away the kids throw away the
key yeah
oh my goodness okay fine we're gonna
have desserts
look at how strong my little helper is
he's so strong he wanted more bags too
we just did a grocery run for the week
every Sunday I try to get this done
and it's so CUNY that now my little my
little man can contribute thank you Duty
okay so grocery shopping I just want to
run down what we got uh for our diet and
what I got for my snacks
okay let's do the diet first so we're
still going to continue our diet after
are you good
after our little cheat Fest
okay don't shoot me dude you're choking
okay
so this is for our diet days we're still
gonna cook so we got some cut onion
um bell peppers I got this from the
Korean supermarket some cucumber salad
or cucumber uh kimchi some pickled
garlic regular garlic noodles I don't
know if how Bart's gonna fit this in his
macros but
well it's not bad 0.8 carb I mean point
eight fat 58 carb point oh my God Seven
protein and they look delicious look at
this okay we got some 99 one
ground turkey we got some 93 7 beef
some fruits taika's favorite
strawberries I got I love this brand
Light and Fit Greek yogurt because it's
12 protein and zero fat baby
some shrimp because it's always a good
time with some shrimp one fat
one carb 15 protein oh yeah
these have just been a lifesaver and I
just like the way they taste I have
Grandma taste buds but the
um macros on these are fine they're not
great but they're fine and then whenever
I'm sick
I like to get some of this some ginger
some honey ginger I'll probably throw in
a lemon if I'm just too sick to go get
ingredients or for whatever reason but
it's super convenient and then some goju
chong and then I saw this hey mama can I
kill this
it's ground beef
well because I need six you just told me
I could eat this by the way in the
supermarket is what you said yes I'll
make you some more no it's okay go ahead
I don't know why you had to interrupt my
vlogging for this well if I'm measuring
it then it's gonna be this much left
I mean nothing's gonna kill you if you
just have is it the fat that's gonna
kill you no I'm just that's Something's
Gonna Eat It okay
um and then we got bok choy
green peppers
so that's on the healthy stuff okay so I
hope I'm able to give you some ideas
what you can do to keep it healthy if
you're also cutting or dieting or just
want to eat better
um but if you don't want to eat better
don't listen to this next part please
don't we saw this and we were like we
gotta try it we don't know what it is
but we're gonna try it
clumpia I want to do it because it still
would fit our macros for fat
10 carb six protein if and only if I put
it in the air of dry air fryer
and I don't put it the way you're
supposed to put it in hot oil
uh frying it so I'll try it in an air
fryer
maybe I can even eat this travel tonight
okay Bart is craving some Mochi we
wouldn't get it this way normally we
would rather have it fresh but you got
to do what you got to do this right here
is so bomb I don't like chocolate but I
will devour this one
and then actually I don't know this just
looked good and I know if I just get one
for myself
Sticky Fingers fat bar over here we'll
get it too so I had to get an extra one
this I just love anything Sesame black
sesame anything
so we got this
and then I got this I have like Grandma
taste buds I'm beginning to realize
because these are my snacks
some of these
some of these
those are bars those are mine because
these are so bomb if you haven't had
them have them I didn't put it in a diet
pot because they're not very diet
friendly but
you know we can sin but have sin you
know what I'm saying so that's it that's
our
plan
a grocery run yep there he goes I think
he drank the whole thing already are you
finished with it no I have Barbie oh
okay but yeah we're about to cook some
dinner
and chill
so that's what you ended up making huh
yeah it's a it came out tasting pretty
good but I was trying to make the Taco
Bell Mexican pizza but I just think
everything is so lean and dry that it
didn't come out that texture I want to
taste it okay go ahead get a big bite
that looks insane
it's not bad
could I got the salsa
I haven't even tasted it before that's
pretty touch damn dog
I wish I would have had some of that
meat
I'm gonna make you some
no because the the Marshalls online is
amazing I got 96 foreign
I'm just kidding I don't even know you
don't know
so
done for tonight my laundry is clean
it's folded it's put away I already have
taika's clothes ready for tomorrow's
school day
um we're ready to rock and roll I love
to leave my kitchen well it's not my
kitchen but my temporary kitchen
clean dishes I'm waiting for these to
dry and I do like to put them away I
like having a fully stocked fridge
like a this one this size for us is just
way too small but as you can see we're
making it work
I have my meats and stuff for the week
my halo top I'm like ready to [ __ ]
work
this week coming up really tried to
prepare myself
to reach all my goals
um
and yeah I like putting my head down on
my pillow at night and going yes I'm
ready to [ __ ] bulldoze the [ __ ]
Monday the week I'm ready to [ __ ]
like that you know what I'm saying
that's how I feel like I really do feel
that way
um so Sunday like the morning I wake up
like Saturday and Sunday I just kind of
wake up and Coast but then Sunday
afternoon bam it's like get it ready I
[ __ ] sound crazy I know I'm sorry but
it really is like this every single
[ __ ] Sunday prepare for attacking the
week and that's how I like to stay
on that note everybody I hope I've
helped you set up for Success even a
little bit and if not I hope I just made
you smile even a little bit and if not
what the [ __ ] am I doing
um at the very very least I've captured
I've captured some really cool family
moments that I can't wait to revisit
when I'm like 75 because if you know me
you know I don't really like to look at
[ __ ] in the past I don't know why
I've I don't know if it's a thing or if
it's not a thing but I just don't tend
to reminisce very much and go look
through things that's I don't have like
those
keepsake boxes you know where people
keep concert tickets and all that [ __ ]
like
I don't keep any of that stuff anyway so
I'm at least grateful that I keep this
documented so until next time thank you
so much and have a great day and see you
later